Emilia Clarke did you get to chat with
everyone backstage yeah kind of did you
get to talk to him yeah I just think
you're wicked it's a game but actually
now is it your daughter I'm sure you
like math along to cake your daughter is
quite the fan huge fan she's a big
friend's obsessive go and mass are you
yes Dominic you have a relative a friend
who's a fan of maths Oh many are sitting
here with you and I'm obsessed with the
new job you've got which I've really
really wanted it's the best job in the
world working in the coffee shop the
woman top gear are you returning the
favor do you watch Game of Thrones Matt
I've watched it the first season and
then I kind of fell out of it and I
tried to watch it decision and I don't
know what's going the good bits you seen
this
[Music]
what is it season six now it's bigger
than ever
yeah who's laughing seriously sounds
like a chicken
I either was going to stop because I
thought there's a mechanical fault but
that's a human being who's that man
there oh well I'm glad you having a nice
time I know I know I do have one request
for me though so would you would you be
able to ask me how I'm doing know
everyone hate you but you can say no no
yes well since they you know have been
up up up to speed on the show yes thank
you what was really embarrassing is when
that walked out I went
[Music]